reject nation we got ourselves a new
trailer from dc uh the world needs
heroes where the thumbnail just says the
batman black adam the flash aquaman and
the lost kingdom and there's new footage
from all that well at least from the
other three i'm pretty sure might have
run their course at the batman already
i don't know it's three hours worth of
material put more out guys if you're
here please leave a like that would be
very much appreciated let's go into this
and see what new footage they have to
offer us
[Music]
who are you under there
what are you hiding
my son dreamt of a better world that's
why he saved me
you can go to any timeline in the
universe
i'd like to save this one
my boy
what could be greater than a king
that's a king to a god a hero
that was smasher
cool
if we don't stand up no one will
all right
[Music]
waiting for you
damn that costume looks sick yeah
are you in
that doctor fate costume looks awesome
yeah wow pierce brosnan looking like a
silver fox way to that doctor oh there's
an adam smasher right there okay i want
to get a clear look right there madam
smasher what is that dr fake costume
again that looked incredible wow that dr
fate one looks like straight out of the
comic that is beautifully realized
golden age right there i think my
introduction to him was really late
pretty sure it was in the injustice game
nor no no one really animated properties
when i was a kid but my most recent
familiarity was the injustice game he's
like uh sorcerer abilities and such
pierce brosnan is actually perfect
casting to play him this other shot
aldous hodges is playing hawkman right
here that is shiny those are
that is heroic if ever i saw a heroic
image interestingly enough like you do
get like that godly element to black
adam at least with all the visuals that
we got from black adam everything about
its palette feels like plucked out of a
comic book funny enough there are some
visual images in here and if anyone in
the dc universe who has upcoming films
has been a champion of snide reverse
there are things that like just look at
this hawkman image oh yeah this looks
like it would be out of a zack snyder
movie it's like it'll be in a slow
motion sequence set to some kind of
really gravitas heavy pop song alves
hodges is good casting for hawkman
especially i mean the attention to
details on like golden feathers and such
are so beautiful to look at they really
bring that that golden age like you said
godly quality to life it feels even
though it's realized with super modern
technology it feels like it's ripped out
of an older era of these kinds of
stories which is really fun to see at
this point in time and then uh the rock
is black adam
i'm not sure yet i'm still like i i know
i'm excited for it i think because black
adam is a really really cool character
not doing some accent as expected you
won't expect the rock to come in here
doing an accident no yeah you got to get
an actual scene like all we've got in
our snippets so far i think the rock is
gonna give it his all i i believe he's
fully committed to this he is passionate
i believe he will bring his charisma the
energy what is like a apt comparison i
would guess i would say like how when i
saw a dead shot in suicide squad i
mainly saw will smith it might be the
similar effect where i'm like but i
liked will smith
well i can absolutely see that it would
be the same thing but i think black
adams is a much different caliber of a
character because of what the role he
plays in the dc
world the years centuries that that
character brings forth as well and he
definitely has more of like an anti-hero
tortured presence here in fact some of
the shots look like out of his hercules
movie except with a bald head
with the anti-hero part you know even
says like my son dreamt of a better
world he saved me so we're really honing
in on the family quality that dwayne the
rock johnson brings normally when i when
i ever you know jump into anything with
you know uh black adam he he's more of
the villainous side or should we really
trust himself we can trust him he's the
rock and i mean i feel like for dwayne
johnson now would be a good time to
level up with a character that is a
little more challenging to his clean and
i mean you know there will be elements
of black adam that will be redeemable
surely he won't be that dastardly but at
the same time i i hope that pushes
dwayne johnson to a new caliber in his
acting as well and i mean it seems like
he really really cares so i would expect
something like that you know yeah it's
just sometimes it looks like you know
dwayne johnson in a costume it does yeah
black adam costing more than anything
else good john cena's black adam man and
then of course we got some clearer looks
i don't remember fully what we got from
the dc fandom when it came to uh aquaman
but you know we got some clearer looks
of his new sleeker costume to go
exploring around
him actually you know sitting on the
throne which i don't think is a shot we
got in the aquaman movie the first one
like he gets the kingdom but if we don't
actually see him sitting on the throne
and now he's just bored of ruling yeah
he's just sitting there waiting for
something to do and the boy and i think
this is gus girl right here is cyclone
if i'm not mistaken i'm not that
familiar with her so i'm not really
gonna touch on her and then
adam smasher is a really cool character
to bring to life yeah i think my first
time seeing adam smasher was actually
when he appeared in the flash yeah i
mean he's got this like ability to
pretty much you know change his body
mass and grow to like maximum size i
think like i i forget the exact height
so 20 something feet but it looks like
what they're doing is they're building
up to some crazy ass epic fight at the
very end of this movie this seems like
it's all within the same location of
where they're fighting whatever whatever
city that they're in yeah i feel like
this fight scene just looks incredibly
epic at the end because it looks like
you got hawkman dr fate adam smasher and
black adam all in this one location here
with the flash you got a better look at
his costume as well that looks really
sleek and you know neat to behold i
actually put together some flash theory
video that i got to share with you guys
on the channel just going gonna take
some time to edit and i mean too just
looking at this promo i think it's fun
too after everything with justice league
to have the justice society assembling
as you know the sort of antagonistic
force to black adam i feel like that's
another fun way that you can get team
introduce some characters we haven't
seen in this format before and also have
it not have all the stakes that like a
justice league movie would have to have
so it feels like there is that expansive
sort of wonder that will be represented
in that sense of team justice but also
presented from the opposite perspective
like justice society of america but all
right guys what did you think about this
little teaser what was your favorite
part about it leave your thoughts down
below engagement matters subscribe click
the notification bell last but not least
let's do a pic
brian perry want to shout you out today
this is a trailer full of justice and
and aspirational figures and i see your
name brian perry you've got an
interesting way of spelling it you're a
unique cat and you just sound like the
kind of person brian perry you would get
into some kind of sci-fi accident come
out with powers and reuse those powers
for the good of humanity brian perry
this is what i think of when i see your
name so uh hey it's february it's the
month of love i hope you got a little
love in your life because we love you we
appreciate your support we appreciate
you being here after several months now
and uh hey happy 2022 hope you're doing
well and we'll talk soon much love buddy
cheers
that made sense
[Music]
you